rires se mettre à l'abri c'est une
télévision russe qui filme l'effroyable
quotidien des habitants de marioupol où
les bombardements incessants ravage la
ville assiégée depuis près de trois
semaines mais mario paul résiste encore
l'ukraine ne déposera pas les armes et
ne quittera pas la ville assiégée la
réponse de la vice première ministre à
l'ultimatum russe exigent la
capitulation de la ville
nous appelons les unités des forces
armées ukrainiennes les bataillons de
défense territoriale et les mercenaires
étrangers à cesser les hostilités et à
entrer dans les territoires contrôlés
par kiev grâce aux couloirs humanitaires
convenu avec la partie ukrainienne et
n'importe quand
l'ultimatum a expiré ce matin des
couloirs humanitaires pourraient se
mettre en place trois cent cinquante
mille personnes sont toujours piégées
dans la ville martyre et charrues sont
entrés dans la ville mais la résistance
ukrainienne f1 rouge
sur ces images filmées par un groupe
nationaliste ukrainien un tank russe est
visé par plusieurs phrases
un soldat sont extraits et part en
courant il n'y a pour l'heure aucune
information sur la progression des
troupes russes
selon les autorités ukrainiennes une
frappe a visé cette école elle abrite et
400 personnes on ignore combien il ya de
victimes
c'est un crime de guerre un crime de
guerre majeure ce qui se passe à
marioupol la ville sera complètement
détruites et les gens meurent à paris
l'europe se réunit aujourd'hui pour
examiner de nouvelles sanctions contre
mouscron et face aux dés